the way we parent leads to the
production of risk-averse frightened
brittle young people
who arrive on campuses and say we don't
want freedom of speech we want freedom
from speech we want biased response
teams to fan out across the campus the
graduates go into corporations and
suddenly delta airlines and coca-cola
and all the rest are woke
how'd that happen i take it all the way
back to the bubble wrap children that
are being produced by today's parenting
[Music]
it's an honor and a pleasure to have on
george will he writes a twice weekly
syndicated column on politics domestic
and foreign affairs for the washington
post's been writing since 74 received
the pulitzer prize for commentary in
1977 he has a brand new book out that is
a compendium of many of the columns he's
written over the years
george thanks so much for joining the
show really appreciate it
glad to be with you so let's talk about
the state of all things since that's
really what your book is about over the
course of the last
several decades i know that the
constitution seems to have gone largely
by the wayside and all of our political
conversations these days but what
strikes me always when people on both
sides talk about the constitution is the
specific focus on the bill of rights and
the complete lack of focus to the actual
structural underlying constitution and
it's that structural underlying
constitution that seems to be most in
danger to me and it also seems to be the
thing that people care the least about
these days
well you're quite right uh first of all
to my strict constructionist friends
constitution day is unconstitutional
because they can't find any enumerated
power justifying this but beyond that
as you know the the framers in
philadelphia did not include a bill of
rights largely because
they argued that the structure of the
constitution itself including the idea
of enumerated powers was such that
it would be unnecessary
to have a bill of rights and furthermore
once they said once you begin to
enumerate the rights we have where do
you stop do we have a right to wear a
hat yes but you have to put that in the
bill of rights and they thought it might
disparage other rights hence the ninth
amendment
uh
but you're quite right
the big problem today isn't the
enforcement of the bill of rights
although they're a problem with that it
is the
utter disequilibrium that's been
injected into the constitution by the
administrative state
congress giving away its powers people
carelessly say oh the president is
usurping powers well if only presidents
had to use circle
the legislature is all too glad to hand
them over on a silver salver to thereby
ducking responsibility for the actual
governance of the united states
and the executive branch itself then is
encouraged by a to lackadaisical court
to lackadaisical to enforce the
non-delegation doctrine saying that you
cannot delegate essentially legislative
powers to non-legislative bodies
and also
by being far too deferential under the
chevron doctrine and all the rest to
administrative
uh interpretations of the law which are
often vague i mean
the
legislature basically passes aspirations
it says
we should have
good education you guys over in the
education department fill in the details
and of course the details are everything
in in legislation we'll get some more of
this in just one second first here is
the reality you don't need to go to the
post office post office is great but you
really want to spend time there why
would you waste your time and waste your
money because the fact is that with
stamps.com you don't have to go to the
post office you can mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters ship
packages and you can pay a lot less
stamps.com saves businesses thousands of
hours and tons of money every single
year here at dailywire we've been using
stamps.com since 2017. we don't waste
our time stamps.com brings the services
of the us postal service and ups
directly to your computer it's a
must-have for any business no wonder
over one million businesses choose
stamps.com for their mailing and
shipping you can simply use your
computer to print official us postage 24
7 for any letter any package any class
of mail anywhere you want to send it
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off it is indeed that
simple with stamps.com you get discounts
up to 40 off post office rates up to 66
off ups shipping rates stop wasting your
time going to the post office head on
over to stamps.com instead no risk with
my promo code shapiro you get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on that
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro that stamps.com promo
code shapiro what you're pointing out
here this is what scares me the most
about sort of the future of the country
because we can focus in on the culture
conflicts which we'll talk about in a
second and which seem to suck up all the
oxygen in the room but the reality is
that the sort of founding vision which
was essentially localism and then you'd
have a federal government that was
capable of mobilizing on a very small
number of issues and there had to be
pretty wide approval across a broad
variety of institutions in order for
that mobilization to occur you had to
have states that appointed senators you
had to have the federal branches agree
with one another you had several
constituencies from the house to the
senate to the judiciary to the
presidency he had enormous levels of
agreement in or gridlock was the purpose
and this is what people seem to have
forgotten is that the structural
constitution was designed to prevent the
government from doing things not
particularly to enable the government to
do all that many things the the
destruction of that is leading to a sort
of winner takes all attitude toward
government in the united states which is
basically we now fight over the gun
there is a gun it exists at the federal
level the president of the united states
is almost an elected dictator who takes
office once every four years does
whatever he wants signs a bunch of
orders uh and all the congress does is
decide how large or small the check is
that the president gets to sign over and
it seems like we are moving from
we move from an actual republican system
to an almost
pre-cromwell
british parliamentarian system where the
parliament was there to basically raise
taxes for the king and then occasionally
not raise taxes for the king and when
they don't raise taxes for the king then
the king just declares personal rule and
starts doing things on his own that's a
very apt and interesting analogy to the
cromwellian government now we have a
lord protector
in the presidency
there's another consequence of what you
described when you concentrate more and
more power away from the states and
localities into the into washington and
more washington power in the executive
branch
and essentially independent agencies
unsupervised by anyone
this is why
since the last
bastion of restraint on the other two
branches of government is the supreme
court this is why the confirmation of
judeo supreme court justices has become
a blood sport because the stakes are
enormous
boyd and gray
has been very active in combating all
this makes a very good point
we see more protests with placards and
all the rest out in front of the supreme
court building than we do outside the
capitol building across the street
because people rightly intuit
that what goes on across the street in
congress is of
secondary or tertiary importance
that the action is in
[Music]
the great marvel
monument to the court built by uh
william howard taft
and you know
george by the way the name of the book
obviously is american happiness and
discontent's the unruly torrent
2008-2020
i think this is leading to an
exacerbation of the culture wars because
when a people feel as though their
concerns are taken into account in the
system when they feel that their
localities are capable of representing
them and not being infringed upon by the
federal government or their states are
more representative of them or the
federal government is capable of
balancing a variety of viewpoints and
then maybe doing nothing when people
feel that their voices are being heard
there's less of a necessity to attack
your neighbor i have to say i i've been
disquieted particularly over the past
couple of months i mean look things have
been ugly in this country for a while
but over the past couple of months the
the the president of the united states
when joe biden gets on national
television and he starts essentially
saying that people should hate their
unvaccinated neighbors because that's
really what is stopping us from
returning to normal it's like this
abdicates all policy duty i mean you
either are
in favor of people having a certain
level
of liberty or you're not but whatever
you're in whatever you're in favor of
are not in favor of what you can't do is
direct one segment of the population
against the other segments of the
population in order to avoid the
political blame for whatever is going on
in terms of policy
my uh
book contains a whole section on
judicial cases and judicial power and
that section is really a monument to my
great change of mind over the last 50
years
when i came to washington i was a
borkian in fact bob pork was a very
close friend
and bork was an oliver wendell holmes
type who celebrated majoritarianism
he said america's about majority rule
uh
who
who said judicial deference this was at
a time when conservatives believe that
the court should defer
to majoritarian institutions from city
councils to congress i no longer believe
that i believe that judicial deference
is often dereliction of duty to police
the excesses of majoritarianism i do not
believe there is a counter-majoritarian
dilemma in judicial review i think the
point of having a written constitution
is to override majorities the
constitution is to do that
the first amendment begins congress
shall make no law abridging
in a way sometimes i wish they'd stopped
right there but congress shall make no
law abridging that even if the country
wants it
even if majorities want it can't have it
sorry
as je as justice jackson said in west
virginia b barnett reversing the
the
flag salute case of 1939 he said in 1943
the very purpose of a bill of rights is
to place certain issues beyond the reach
of majorities above the vicissitudes of
majoritarian politics
we'll get some more on this in just one
second first life is unexpected so you
do need life insurance i mean let's say
that you go roller skating but you do it
near a cliff and then you are over the
edge of a cliff like wiley coyote you
look down and
well as you fall you might think to
yourself man that was a bad idea and
also i really should have gotten that
life insurance from policy genius you
could save 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
it could save 1300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies the licensed
experts of policy genius work for you
not the insurance companies so you can
trust them to help you navigate every
step of the shopping and buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five-star reviews
across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor higher than options from
ladder ethos and bestow getting started
is easy first you can head on over to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much life insurance coverage you
need and compare personalized quotes to
find your best price when you're ready
to apply the policy genius team will
handle the paperwork and scheduling for
free policy genius does not add on extra
fees head on over to policygenius.com
get started right now policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice and
quite important to get it right
i agree with you that that judicial
activism is not the same thing as as
judicial misinterpretation i think these
two things have been conflated in pretty
radically stupid ways and it is not
judicial activism to say that something
that clearly violates the constitution
is unconstitutional and it as you say it
should not be a matter of whether a
majority passed it if it hadn't passed
it presumably wouldn't be in front of
the supreme court in the first place as
a general rule the real question is
whether the judiciary
is correct in striking a thing down or
not striking down but you're right that
the supreme court is the sole kind of
break on the authoritarian state
i think this is leading to the the real
possibility that the country starts to
fall into more and more chaos i said
this a couple of days ago on my show
my great fear is that what's happening
right now is that california and texas
are polarizing obviously california and
florida are polarizing we moved our
family from california to florida for
many reasons including that polarization
and the sort of self-sorting mechanism
that's happening uh has happened before
in american life but it's happening
pretty radically right now and as the
federal government moves forward there's
gonna be a choice to be made and that is
does the federal government continue to
centralize power in the
in the administrative state which is
likely to break the system it's likely
to ossify the the halls of power to make
them unresponsive to these various
states and the diversity of the american
people and likely to break the thing
and
more importantly than that i mean i'm
wondering at a certain point if the
administrative state becomes so ossified
that even the president can't control
the administrative state at which point
essentially it doesn't matter who you
elect president the administrative state
is going to do what it wants well the
consumer financial protection bureau
which is the brainchild of elizabeth
warren is a monument to that it's con
it's financed not by an appropriation
from congress but by the profits from
the federal reserve system
uh
the head of it can be removed only for
god knows what uh it's not clear but
he's certainly not at the pleasure of
the president which undermines the
unitary executive
and all of this you know is taking place
against the backdrop of something i
think you and i both agree which is that
the truism
that politics is downstream from culture
and the culture is moving in so many
different ways when i put my book
together i was startled by how often
i've been writing about parenting
and about how the way we parent leads to
the production of risk-averse frightened
brittle young people
who arise arrive on campuses and say we
don't want freedom of speech we want
freedom from speech we want biased
response teams to fan out across the
campus
and police safe spaces against
microaggressions and all the other
nonsense that's come up
this of course what happens on campus
doesn't stay on campus it leaks the
graduates go into corporations and
suddenly delta airlines and coca-cola
and all the rest are woke
how'd that happen i take it all the way
back to the bubble wrap children that
are being produced by today's parenting
the book is american happiness and
discontents the unruly toran 2008 to
2020. you know george when you talk
about the sort of bubble wrap parenting
you can see this actually throughout
american society the sense of safetyism
that has crept into american society is
pretty astonishing now when it came to
covid i
was you know worried about cover because
my parents are 65 they were essentially
with us during the entire pandemic and
so i was not against the original
lockdowns before we knew the data i was
not even against the idea that you
should mask when you are in the presence
of vulnerable people if you are if you
are unvaccinated and they're
unvaccinated but we've that was all free
vaccine when i say that we've reached to
the point of safety isn't what i mean is
that we uh every day essentially i see a
piece in the media about how unsafe the
vaccinated are i mean we have the
president of the united states get on
national television and say that the
vaccinated need to be protected from the
unvaccinated that safety isn't its
finest once i took the vaccines and my
parents took the vaccines i actually
followed the data they are about as safe
as safe can be they are safer than they
are from the flu at which point you need
to go out and you need to live regular
life but it seems as though there's a
certain level of comfort in feeling
unsafe and in the idea that the
president of the united states and the
federal government can save you from
every travail of life whether it is
the possibility of eviction or whether
it is the possibility that you might get
a breakthrough case of covid that
results in having to stay home for a
couple of days
some people just love the regimentation
inherent in public health protocols and
they will want them to be forever
you know you you've noticed this for
ever since the the latter half of
franklin roosevelt's initial
uh inaugural address in which he said
we'd have to be as though we were armed
we were being invaded by an army to
fight the depression we've made war on
the depression war on poverty war on
drugs war on cancer war on pornography
war war war why because
it suggests the american people should
be marshaled in syria ranks obedient to
commands from above we've even heard in
the current pandemic and vaccine fight
say well of course the president can
exercise the general police power that
we thought inherited in the states to
order vaccines why because george
washington
ordered the inoculation of his soldiers
well yes
if americans are related to the central
government the way a soldier is to his
commanding officer but we're not
and we don't want to live in a martial
state a garrison state and be treated
like this there's more on this in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact you don't want to go to the auto
parts store what's so great about the
auto parts store you stand in line you
get to the front of the line the doof
behind the counter asks you a bunch of
questions you answer them finally you
get through the process and he's like
well we'll have that in a couple of
weeks you're like wait what you don't
have it's like right well why don't you
just do it on the internet yourself
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do why spend up to
twice as much for the same parts
furthermore prices at rockauto.com are
always the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers their family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about usbox so they know that
we sent you rockauto.com go check them
out right now and again write shapiro in
there how did you hear about xbox so
they know that we sent you because why
would you go to the auto parts store
where you could just do everything using
the magic of the interwebs rockauto.com
so george let's talk for a second about
where conservatism stands because really
this should be a pretty target-rich
environment for conservatives and we've
been talking about problems that i think
most americans are deeply unhappy with
ranging from the sort of
movement away from an aggressive
american foreign policy under joe biden
to an extraordinarily
intrusive state to culture wars that
frankly the left has moved too far too
fast on and the polls tend to show that
it should be sort of a good situation
that conservatives are in and yet
conservatives seem not to be in a
particularly good situation they may be
you know okay electorally in 2022 maybe
in 2024 depending on who gets nominated
but there is this sort of gap between
the policy
possibilities for conservatives pushing
back against the left and then the sort
of
failure to break out of an attitude that
is more concerned at this point with how
do we offend the left rather than how do
we defeat the left
good point
the pursuit of happiness has been
distorted because happiness is now
defended as
understood as producing the unhappiness
of the other team
instead of a kind of affirmation of the
joy of being an american the joy of
being an american consists in the fact
that we define happiness on our own and
we pursue it with voluntary association
with others
in in the spontaneous order of a market
society because when the market stops
allocating wealth and opportunity
politics will and when paula to the
extent that politics
allocates wealth and opportunity the
stakes of politics go up and the
bitterness goes up because the cost of
losing goes up
and this becomes an awful intensifying
spiral
that's producing today's america
which is why i i believe that as
more and more
so-called conservatives
become what i call hyphenated
capitalists common good capitalism
therefore or some other adjective to
modify capitalism
all they're doing is drifting into
cronyism
and the rent seeking that is already
pandemic in this country
that will produce a bitterness as i've
said but also slower economic growth and
therefore distributional conflicts that
will further intensify our politics
i totally agree with this i mean i think
that one of the things that i was
talking with some friends about recently
was the idea that for a lot of common
good conservatives the idea is not that
there should be you know some sort of
common good governance at the local
level right subsidiary seems to matter
very little to most people these days is
why federalism mattered so much to the
founders it is one thing for you and
your friends at a very local level to
decide between yourselves that you want
to run things you know like a nuclear
family uh it is another thing to extend
that out to people you don't even want
to share bread with and as the
government grows and as the government
is left unchecked you basically now have
a fight between the left that wants to
use government to help their friends and
the right that wants to use government
to help their friends and the reality is
that half the country is not friends
with the other half of the country i
think that we are looking at at
something that that is going to approach
an almost brexit situation but i don't
know how that plays out in american
constitutional system
i don't think it does i mean we're stuck
with one another and and the sooner
people realize that the better
deep breath everybody you know in the
19th century we fought
bitterly to the point of
dismembering the country but they were
big issues
could one group of human beings own
another group of human beings could they
take their human property into the
territories
big stuff how to fund the government by
tariffs or
income tax
or the sale of public lands
these were issues people were hot about
but you could say here's how you address
them legislatively up or down fugitive
slave law yes or no
how do you write a law
that addresses anxieties that are
essential class resentments
i don't know how you do it which is why
when politics has a difficult time
getting a purchase on the real
grievances people have which are
emotional and status related
then politics becomes a performative art
and you get
you get the united states senate today
we totally agree with that george i
think one of the things that that
obviously is so troubling is that people
are looking for love in all the wrong
places where the drunk the proverbial
drunk searching for the car keys under
the lamppost we're trying to use eco
economics to solve problems of soul
we're trying to use the government to
solve problems of soul and politics to
try to solve all those problems those
problems of soul aren't going to go away
on their own and it seems like they are
being greatly exacerbated by things like
social media they're being greatly
exacerbated by lack of community fabric
and that that does have to do with the
decline of institutions like churches
i'm not sure how we recover that
yeah well first of all
abandon social media would be a great
start people won't
i i i don't tweet i don't know how to
tweet
the tweets are done in my name twice a
week they're just excerpts from my
columns i'm told i have a facebook page
i've never seen it
i don't get the point
uh i happen to believe that books remain
the primary carriers of ideas
and i believe that moynihan was right
when he said in the 1970s something
momentous has happened conservatism
conservatives and the republicans have
become the party of ideas
and in its post-war great uh growth
conservatism was a very bookish outfit
beginning with
richard weaver's book ideas have
consequences i've lived 80 years and i
am more and more convinced that only
ideas have large and lasting
consequences and that books are still
the primary carriers of these ideas
so the the certainly tweets
they're wonderful for vituberation
they're wonderful for venting
but carrying ideas i don't think so
well george will obviously uh an
institution all on his own in american
life his brand new book is american
happiness and discontents the unruly
torrent 2008-2020 go pick up a copy
because it is always filled with gems
and excellent thinking and great ideas
and stuff that is well worth mulling
over for years to come george really
appreciate the time as always
i it's great fun to talk with you and i
hope you do it again soon
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment